hi everyone I'm Tamara Rodriguez I'm the
head of equity engineering at Google and
today I'll be talking to you a little
bit about a team I started called equity
engineering the impact and the
opportunity of designing for Google's
most vulnerable users first really
excited to talk to you today and thank
you so much for being here with us
before we get started let's talk a
little bit about what equity engineering
is equity engineering is a comprehensive
approach to building equitable products
for underrepresented and future users
and what does that mean when I say
equity oftentimes people wonder if I'm
talking about the stock market or
financial products but really equity is
a concept and a has a definition of
providing the tools and services and
opportunities to different users that
they need in order to make sure that
they have outcomes that suit their needs
but also that meet them where they are
right so working across different
communities what are the tools and
services and perspectives that need to
be understood in order to make sure that
we are building products and services
that help all of our users and don't
advantage some users to the disadvantage
of others but more about that in a
minute let's get through the agenda and
talk about how we're gonna walk through
this pretty complex topic so the first
thing that we're gonna do is talk about
what are our pillars what are the
guideposts that we use in order to frame
this work then we're gonna step into our
goals fundamentally what are we focused
on how do we do it what is the model
that we use in order to get the work
done and what is our approach in
continuing to advance this work across
Google lastly we'll talk about the
impact or to some areas of opportunity
and some traction that we've made
what is our moonshot and by the way what
is a moonshot what do Googlers mean
when they say that and then we'll talk
about some key takeaways that you can
incorporate into your own practice into
your teams and hopefully into your
company
so equity engineering some fast facts
about US equity engineering is a
multi-domain cross-product area effort
that evaluates processes consumer
products and internal systems we
facilitate more equitable experiences
and outcomes for users through process
experimentation in partnership with the
chief diversity office and all
applicable product areas we really have
some lofty guideposts the first one is
we want to transform development we want
to infuse a mindset of diversity equity
and inclusion throughout product
development and engineering at Google
and we have a specific theory of change
of where to start
so we'll talk about that in a little bit
as well how do we know where to start
how do we do this work we want to
centralized research we really believe
that ethical user experience research
that is focused on constructing user
journeys and product roadmaps that
directly impact underrepresented or
marginalized groups is where we begin as
priority zero we also want to make sure
that we're building capacity we want
other teams and other technologists to
understand how to that approach this
work independently so we teach and
develop technologists to understand and
prioritize use cases that negatively
impact underrepresented users we also
understand that underrepresented users
look and act differently throughout the
world as a multinational organization we
know that we have different tools and
different research for different places
around the world we really work on being
multi-ethnic multinational cross
perspective in order to include as many
users as possible so we really are
beginning as a horizontal team with
scope that focuses on HR first-party
tools tools that are built by Google for
Google and third-party tools tools that
are used across the industry that we
have incorporated at Google now I'm sure
you're wondering why start with HR first
well at Google our hiring and
professional development process things
are very tailored to the way that Google
does business when I started this team I
wanted to focus on accelerating Google's
goals to build a more diverse workplace
first it's a core philosophy that I hold
and that I wanted to bring into the team
around cleaning up your own home first
our theory of change is that as we bring
in more people from all walks of life
our products will be better and more
inclusive by default if their creators
come from more places around the world
from different socioeconomic classes
from different religions perspectives
and walks of life therefore we want to
start with the most pressing issue how
do we make Google a workplace that
reflects the beautiful variability and
diversity of our communities around the
world this is a core value and something
that differentiates our work from other
products inclusion initiatives that seek
to educate the existing workplace well
education is an important tenant of our
mission equitable hiring progression and
inclusive culture are our first priority
secondly we want to scale our impact by
joining forces we want everyone at the
table we want to make sure that Google
program managers engineers
product managers UX researchers across
the company have an opportunity to
really focus on how we can advance these
goals internally first and then more
broadly throughout the industry and
throughout the world we also make sure
that each of our partners are dedicated
to the development of products and
systems that work for our users
especially our most vulnerable users we
want to drive parity across those
experiences and taking a quick step back
driving parity means we want to make
sure that our you
sirs who are enjoying the most benefits
who feel the most psychologically safe
and who are able to really advance their
careers that there is not a delta
between their experiences and other
groups we want our groups that are
having a more difficult time to have an
easier go at building the best careers
that they can at Google at being
progressed and being valued and so
therefore our goal is really to make
sure that first within Google and then
throughout the industry and for all of
our users that everyone has the same
opportunity and the same outcomes and
how they're able to enjoy a career at
Google to enjoy our products and also to
benefit from the prosperity that comes
from technology and the sector at large
that was a lot and definitely those
goals seem pretty good sounds really
good on paper right but how do we get
this done well we get it done with a
theoretical framework a partnership
model that helps teams understand how
they can be successful what are their
core responsibilities but where are the
opportunities to collaborate so from the
key performance indicator side what the
opportunity assessments are with
diversity equity and inclusion we think
it's really important to defer to the
teams that have expertise in this area
and so in that regard we partner really
closely with the chief diversity office
to make sure that we understand what is
Google's broad diversity strategy what
is the prioritization and also what are
the opportunity assessments that we can
carry forward we then help to drive
cultural change by creating pilots
training and documentation for our
technologists in order to help inform
the product strategy the area priorities
and team objectives and key results and
then lastly we empower all of the teams
across the diversity office and also
product teams by providing consultations
and referrals either internally or
externally to experts in industry we
help with prototypes and experiments so
that we can innovate in ways that help
us to create rapid opportunity
assessments and we do reviews for
existing products that are in flight and
ready to be produced or produce and
ready to launch within Google so now
let's talk a little bit about the
collaboration model and how it's driven
so much impact here across our company
to date and I it's really difficult to
process but today just over the last 18
months we have worked across 72
different teams across alphabet
oftentimes an issue that we think only
impacts Google really impacts multiple
of our butts and so we've had the
pleasure of really working across the
entire alphabet
and we've done that by helping to
elevate sensitive use cases often times
when we're thinking about marginalized
users we really want to make sure that
we take the burden off of those
communities from having to describe
their own challenges with our processes
and our products and so we hope to
elevate the sensitive use cases and help
to protect users from further
psychological harm
we also help to inform process design so
oftentimes in engineering it's not just
thinking about what the tools do but
it's also thinking about what are the
processes right how do we create a
professional development paradigm where
users from all different kinds of
backgrounds can learn and grow and
understand what their next steps are
that then informs our product design
right for a lot of Google's processes as
we said it's really unique to the way
that Google does business and so
therefore our products can be quite
unique as well working product and
process together helps drive mindful
innovation that focuses on our
underrepresented users we also then help
with launches as we're getting ready to
deploy these tools and processes are we
thinking about all of the right things
do we have all our checks and balances
in place and then lastly even when
something is launched there's a lot of
change manager that comes along and so
our program managers help with change
management across the teams that we're
working with to help lay in that load
what we found is we dug across our
company is that there were many
opportunities for us to work with
different teams on improving products
and processes we have identified over a
hundred and fifty nine improvements 81%
of those have already launched and we
know that we're on track to make
progress in 2020 which is really
rewarding considering all the challenges
that the seer has brought we see
ourselves moving this work forward and
helping to improve the space just a
little bit even through some of the
hardest times we want to make sure that
our growth is sustainable and then it
can be and that it is in fact sustained
and so our resourcing in 2020 and moving
forward is around distribution across
multiple disciplines here at Google we
call those disciplines
and essentially refers to different
domains of expertise and so right now
we're working with user experience
program management product management
and software engineering we believe that
a cross-functional and cross
organizational model is going to help
our work to scale and it's going to help
everyone invest in this very important
work we also know that specificity
matters and so we maintain a core
working group of 10 specialists that
really think about equity creases across
multiple topics that impact our company
and industry so back to this moonshot
what does it mean when Googlers say we
are aiming towards a moonshot or our
moonshot a moonshot is a google term for
any big long-term expensive project to
solve an extremely challenging problem
that has a chance of failing but if we
succeed could fundamentally change
society an expensive can mean anything
it can mean time it can mean sweat
equity
it can mean financial resources or
prioritization but the term alludes to
fundamentally this raised between 1955
to 1972 to race to the moon as part of
the Apollo program many said it was
impossible
there were many failures along the way
and it's the path towards progress
certainly wasn't linear but it is
definitely worthwhile
and so our moonshot is just as lofty and
just as challenging we believe that
structural discrimination is a form of
institutional discrimination and we know
that that has a real impact in
engineering we understand that systemic
bias is an unintended outcome that
results from a lack of representation of
women older workers black and Latin X
people non-binary and transgender people
but we do believe that we can dismantle
the systemic bias and engineering
globally and that's really the core
moonshot we want to empower and drive
access to the tech industry at large
we understand that in the rarefied air
of
means like Google there are many people
who never get an opportunity to have
their voices heard and we want to make
our company in our industry more
accessible to those people not just in
the United States but all over the world
we want to them share our findings in
the open source community we want to
promote universal equitable frameworks
because this is really about improvement
and effecting change not just for
ourselves but the company to companies
like us to the industry and to users and
people at large with that what can we do
to effect change and since I'm sharing
this with you what can you do to affect
change the first thing that I'm going to
ask you to do is to take a hard look in
the mirror at Google we have the brand
slogan build for everyone but how can we
actually build for everyone when we do
not have a representative workforce or
engagement model that centralizes the
community's feedback first truth is we
can't we have to really focus on our
most vulnerable users we have to be
aware of the ways that our products can
either advantage or disadvantage groups
and we have to start thinking about our
most vulnerable users first with that we
know that we can't build for everyone
we're building on behalf of everyone we
want to build with everyone the work
cannot happen in a vacuum
and it certainly does not happen or will
not happen when the technology sector as
a whole is still failing at
representation in hiring and in
retention that said we're also not going
to pack up and go home so how do we
build for everyone we built with our
users we need to engage our users across
the spectrum of humanity engage our
users that are the least like us and to
be intentional about centralizing them
first not as an afterthought we also
want to design for the user that has the
most difficulty accessing the product
building for those who have additional
challenges our
going to make our product better for
everyone another way of thinking about
this is never trade-off accessibility or
any other equity issue for short-term
velocity measure once measure twice
three times before you cut right good
sound practice measure equity throughout
your systems do not assume it recognize
that your decision makers are also
subject to bias and can be undereducated
in the causes of inequity so therefore
you need a mixed method research you may
not have the expertise to identify or
measure the scope of an equity issue
that's okay a lot of us weren't trained
to understand this and so while we're
not responsible for the lack of
knowledge we are accountable to gaining
the information remember that if you
cater to a single user base you may
defeat this in franchising another these
trade-offs can be hard to spot and
impossible to reverse so be proactive
partner with teams and individuals that
are subject matter experts and diversity
equity and inclusion and don't be scared
to go outside of your team or even
outside of your company it's a big task
it's a hard one it is most definitely a
moonshot if not many but I want to leave
you with the thought that change is
possible
the problems that we're facing with
technology today everything from
surveillance to disinformation to online
harassment are genuinely overwhelming
and it's okay if you have moments of
feeling overwhelmed we're not going to
solve these problems overnight but we're
also not going to solve with the same
failed approaches of the past or just
the skills we already have so take a
moment to think about what are the tools
services and skills that have gotten us
here meditate on that but then further
think what are the tools skills and
services that we need to get to the next
iteration of what we would like
technology to be and how we would like
humans that access
these tools and who gets to be part of
not just the prosperity but also of the
development of the tools and services
that help people all over the world we
know that we need to change and I want
to leave you with the thought that it's
possible for us to change if we all get
in together thank you so much for your
time and thinking about learning about
equity engineering